[Music]
and it gets weirder news submitted by
the Lannisters I like of an adopted
child say they've been frauded and the
girl is actually an adult an adult
sociopath whoa
yeah one more time okay parents of an
adopted child say they've been frauded
and the girl is actually an adult
sociopath what if it was like Gary
Coleman were or like Andy Milonakis were
like they still look young but then
they're actually older and then they get
like adopted and if you're like oh look
at this cute kid and they're actually
crazy you literally just said what she
isn't there like a whole movie about
that where there's like a little girl
called orphan yeah and she like pulls
her teeth out it is like that so okay
but is it true there are two versions of
this story I'm gonna tell you both
versions but they both have the same
facts right so we can just decide who we
want to believe so in this first version
I'm gonna tell you some facts this
couple already had a child his name is
Jake he has autism he's been diagnosed
with autism since he was 2 he grew up to
be a child prodigy he like is this math
and physics whiz and he got a paper
published at 12 and accepted to this
like crazy physics Institute 15 yeah and
so also the ultimate nation they adopted
this Ukrainian girl from the Ukraine and
but she had come over with a different
adoptive family and then something fell
through and so they had to do like a
last-minute adoption and they like had
it was like a 24 hour turnaround type
thing and she was a six year old girl
and they were like of course we want to
grab weight was the first kid adopted
their genius no oh that was there that
was there a kid yeah question I don't
know anything about the orphan business
but in the orphan business do they have
kids that are like more on sale
I don't know these kids are like you
know when you go to fucked-up kids the
shoe store where the shoes he can't sell
for three seasons
that's like 50% I think they're all on
sale I think it's the whole bargain
basement over there it's like it's like
the shelter it's actually really hard to
a doctor in LA but it really
not like a premium pet store it's more
like the LA County shelter yeah but not
some of them are more incentive to get
this kid I don't know because all you
say it at this quick I wonder if there's
like premium breeders - yeah there are
like when they when they harvest age
like depending on how well your IQ level
is and what your genetics is like well I
mean yeah cuz you could get really
innovative you know like like if you're
if you're buying sperm or some [ __ ]
right or like eggs or whatever you could
like pick them yeah but like when does
it when does it get like not moral like
wit you know like I sure alright like in
different countries it'll be like we
have these parents they're very tall
they're very intelligent and then like
you can adopt their newborn and whatever
before the baby is born they arranged
that with the parents way ahead of time
anyway yeah in this rut don't you want
to know what happened I do but I just
didn't know if this orphan was on the
clear she wasn't on discount oh sure she
was just like oh I need help because my
adoption fell through
can you help and they were like yes
we've been wanting to adopt they're like
on the short list of parents that were
like ready to adopt why would they watch
it when they already have a genius in
the house well because he went off to
physics school and so people want to
have their own kid and some people want
like they want to have both I think when
I'm an adult I'll have one kid and then
adopt another that's nice yeah cuz I one
didn't have a sibling but I don't want
to go through the pain yeah so this may
say we treat she like she says she wants
to she wanted to give life give a better
life to as many people as she could
because she felt very privileged and she
was like I could just make one person's
life better it would be great that's
tired yeah so well then so so they they
knew right away that she did have this
bone disorder as a rare bone growth
disorder that results in dwarfism but if
even when they interviewed the mom okay
so they abandoned this girl at eight
years old they changed her birth date so
that it said that she was 22 and they
left her in an apartment while they went
off to Canada her first parents know
this Vicente parents so when you hear
this story it's like she got adopted by
these people
she's six years old two years later
she's eight years old they leave to
Canada to go help their autistic son
with the physics stuff and they bought
her her own apartment changed her
birthday so it says she was 22 years old
and like left her there
that's crazy eating she must have been a
[ __ ] huge problem yes so now they're
Guinea so now the parents are getting in
trouble this is five years later and
they're they're getting detained and so
she survived there for five years like
like a like a full-grown adult yeah well
yeah well so she had some people come in
and be like oh there's this little girl
like living next door we need to save
her and they're the alerted authorities
and then the authorities were like holy
[ __ ] and then like five years later they
got the parents back over there and like
they're yeah come on in
let's go do these so the parents are
like this what other parents is like
okay our first kid it's kind of [ __ ]
genius when he was eight he couldn't do
all these things drive a car get into
college you're eight can't you do the
same thing see you later I'm a bio
apartment but he didn't realize that the
other kid wasn't as smart as the first
year it's funny is what if they just
like self-diagnosed the kid to be a
sociopath because their first kid was
autistic right so that's their like
foundation of what they think a kid is
yeah and the second one is just like a
normal kid you're like oh this one's
[ __ ] nuts
yeah backwards it got approved by the
courts to change her age to 22 okay
after seeing these papers why yeah yes
so the courts in Indianapolis are like
yeah we think you're right they changed
her age to 22 and that's where it gets
really weird cuz like in this first
article it's it kind of makes the mom
seem crazy because the dad and her
divorced and the dad's like yeah I
always knew she was a little girl but my
ex-wife would coach her to say that she
was 22 and so it sounds like the mom is
kind of nutty but then you read this
other article where it gets more into
details and she when they first of all
when they first adopted her the girl
couldn't walk she was six years old and
they weren't told that the girl couldn't
walk so they were having to carry her
everywhere well then they go to the
beach they used to go to the beach on
the weekends and one of the times she's
up there on the beach and she wants to
go in the water so she was like please
carry me in the water and they're like
we're kind of tired
now I just give us like 10 minutes and
she was like no I want to go in the
water now and she just gets up and runs
into the water
what so that was weird this doesn't
butterfly she couldn't walk forever and
then also and she can run so she was
lying about that that's weird
then they were giving her a bath the
second weird thing was that she's six
years old but she had a period come out
she that comes later but she had full
pubic hairs Oh years old so they were
like this is not normal for a
six-year-old so that's when they started
having and then they found like bloody
clothes that she was trying to hide from
having her period so then they had they
brought her in to get her bone density
tested so they could actually find out
her real age because the birth
certificates popped it's like not
anywhere they can't find it they test
for her real age and the first time they
get tested they're like yeah she's about
eight years old like years later so like
yeah it's it's an eight year old and
then they're like we're not sure so they
go to this other place and they're like
no they looked at her teeth she had
fuller adult teeth all adult teeth and
they're like they measured a couple
other things and they said even with
dwarfism the girl would still be growing
at least an inch over the past two years
she hadn't grown at all so they
speculated that she was actually 22
years old and though the other reason
they were bringing her in for testing is
that she started getting really murdery
so she tried to push the wife into an
electric fence
oh she was shouting that she wanted to
kill her and she wanted to see her die
she was like I want to see you die and
like was pushing her into this electric
fence which is like three feet tall oh
yeah yeah but then another time hey hey
little things can be scary like [ __ ] you
gotta bail the dog yeah but Annabelle
does have full pubic hair yeah yeah so
then paint another period which is even
crazier another time the mom was turning
the corner and saw her the little girl
pouring bleach into her coffee my mom
was like what are you doing and she goes
I'm trying to poison you this is Adam
yeah and then at times she would tell
everyone she's like I'm gonna kill this
whole family and they had to hide all of
the knives in the whole house and they
would wake up to her in the middle of
the night like spearing over them in bed
oh yeah and she said that she would do
it when the time was right why don't
they just kick her she's like beat her
ass she's 20 that's when I named me like
you could make her stay outside like if
you watch the movie orphan like they
really loved they wanted to love her
like they found out she was 22 she's
getting that ass yes
place too so that she can get evaluated
and all of the professionals there were
like yeah she has like a psychological
disorder that we only see in adults like
she's actually a sociopath and but then
when they went to like now that they're
being questioned about it they can't
find any of these documents that prove
that like she's this 22 year old so she
who's the real sociopath right but then
you look at this lady and she was
running a foster care she had this like
adult like this child prodigy and then
she was on 60 minutes like talking about
like the Sun and then she had a faucet
cure but she still wanted to adopt well
that's kind of how you get into being
able to adopt that fast is like you have
to prove that you're but if the kid
still like telling people I'm eight
years old guys I mean yes so basically
so after they abandoned her they were
like okay she's 22 they got her age
officially changed like legally changed
on her birth certificate and they the
mom was like hey I I wanted to give her
the best life she could get I could give
her with you Randall but it was just too
scary like we couldn't stay in that
household this wasn't a child this was
actually an adult and she was a
psychopath and I couldn't put my family
in danger but I still wanted to help her
because I still like had the best
intentions
so they actually loved one else's
brother he paid for the apartment for a
year they picked out furniture together
and the child actually admitted several
times that she was over 18 well why does
it I mean can't we just like close the
case and like have her get tested by
professionals yeah so
guess it's well plays a mom and they
can't find those paper they can't get
one yeah they can't find the papers and
the person that tested and said that it
was she was 22 like they're now saying
that they're not sure or where they
can't find the papers or where they said
that or whatever because this is five
years later but it like the courts have
agreed that like they still agree with
the initial verdict that shoot is 22
yeah it's not a lawyer if you're a
lawyer and trying to present the case
that she is 22 and you have three facts
right pubic hair
yeah teeth that's a fully grown woman no
I don't know she's full grown she's
about six
she looks [ __ ] she has a dolt she has a
I said adult ism she's got Dorf isn't
she need to get a [ __ ] job that's it
that's the verdict yeah get a job like a
little girl to me I guess she's been
pulling this over on a lot of people so
after they left her in the apartment
they're like she seemed like she was
like okay I'm gonna turn my life around
but then they found out she was like
tricking the neighbors and like when the
parents went back to visit they found
like a little girl's dress like a
princess dress in her closet and like a
little tricycle on the side of the
building so they're like oh she's she's
doing that thing again where she's
pretending to be a child or is she a
child we don't know because there's not
any like how humans to be like she's for
sure a 22 year old or she's for sure I
thought there should be there shouldn't
has she been taking care of herself
that's my question
like other concerned adults were like oh
no this kid is has been a big yeah but
if she's like that home cooking like a
full-on meal yeah six year olds can't do
that
but no one sees that because their doors
are closed see that's what I want to see
if she's out there smoking a cigarette
and [ __ ] doing some like other couple
tried to adopt her after being that she
was like left they're like we want to
adopt this child and that's why it
brought the original family back into
the states and they objected being like
this is this is a 22 year old you can't
adopt her pull down her pants you got
the Pugh beep yeah look at
thing and then the courts were like oh
actually we think we think she's 22 like
you can't adopt oh wow that's scurry
yeah I just want to hear what she that's
like Chucky's man like how is she still
trying to convince them like no I'm a
kid I mean again look at her she looks
like a kid he does look I can't accept
like I would kick the [ __ ] out of her
like a football
look at this posture though hold on okay
hey that's why okay trust kids man I
don't know it kind of you could kind of
see it is that bad yeah like as being an
adult she's gonna at all I see that
she's a little is that damn yeah I don't
trust anyone that wears Hollister
they're lying he's divorced okay where's
Tim for that good lady
so they divorced after all of this yeah
well they divorced a couple years ago
before they got pulled back for
questioning and how did they even find
this girl because she was like abandoned
that that's what I want to know cuz what
she found them
Oh originally they didn't ask too many
questions because if she's just chilling
at the party she's like yeah I'm kind of
not like it's not working out with me
and my you know adoptive parents oh well
we're looking to adopt like how the [ __ ]
did that happen yeah well she her orphan
she's a foster right yeah and so well I
don't know if she was originally a
foster or they called the foot because
oh she had her family runs the foster
home
but all they heard was that this
adoption process fell through and that
this girl needed an adoptive parents
immediately and then they were on the
list because they run this foster home
okay um so she was like okay yeah no but
she could have been running a scam with
her friends in the Ukraine yeah but the
other thing is she doesn't have a
Ukraine accent and she can't remember
anything about her homeland and so she's
about you except she's not from UK at a
Ukraine friend come over and speak the
native language and the girl couldn't
understand anything there was so she was
she's a scam artist yeah she's born and
raised in America she's like
articulating - does she sound like this
he's talking like a city no
she uses adult verbage like she has a
very advanced dress she's saying like
word
big-ass words outrageous Larry and then
okay so because the white kids kind of
sound like that the mom but the mountain
runs this daycare right and like one
time the girl was watching the daycare
and was like I don't know how you deal
with all these children and she just
said it like an adult like she's like I
would I'd be going for my kids like that
though that's a peak like adults
that's true but this is somebody that
deals with a lot of children and that's
wild
this this girl didn't even have their
like tone of a child the parents [ __ ]
up by just abandoning him and they
should have been like hey I don't want
us to look suspicious this is yeah yeah
yeah so they have been released on a
$5,000 bail but yeah they're still going
through this she was doing some crazy
[ __ ] to she was jumping out of moving
cars
she was smearing blood on mirrors she
was like doing things that you wouldn't
imagine a child doing and she was
threatening to kill the whole family all
the time it's a movie [ __ ] you keep her
in your household or would you know I'd
call the cops on that [ __ ] yeah yeah
yeah so I'm just gonna say it's [ __ ]
weird that they paid for an apartment
laughter there call the police exactly I
would call the police
and then take our pants awesome the cops
come they know what they're dealing with
okay but if but if you had a child and
they were like out of control and you
called the cops on them the cops to be
like that's your problem that's why the
pubic has to show they gots an adult so
you you pants that summer if I could put
it was as soon as I figure out she's 22
I kick her out put a restraining order
on the thing that they had to approve
they had to prove she was 22 and that's
why they were able to leave her because
they're too nice this is what happens
when you're too nice yeah but once they
want to adopt people that's your problem
yeah
is there a John a doctor under 18 under
18 so once they see this she's 22 does
that cancel the adopt dude yeah that's
where that's how they were able to get
away oh yeah crazy let's use it for all
the good adopted kid potential yeah
[Music]
[Music]